a school year unlike any other they've
known
staggered classes mandatory hand
sanitizing
and of course one vital piece of uniform
the face mask
but when the number of infections in any
given area becomes
overwhelming they too are forced to
close
students then left at the mercy of their
home circumstances
especially those from households where
parents are still going out to work
i'm a mother and i also have a job to do
so i'm worried about
leaving my kid alone at home during the
pandemic i don't know if she will eat on
time
and study by herself staying at home
alone without the company of her friends
may also cause some psychological
problems and i feel sad about this
with parents taking on the role of
educators juggling their work and
teaching has left many fearing for their
children's futures
digital learning has taken over the
classroom
but for those who have children with
special learning needs that can mean
an extra expense on already strained
household budgets
i have a child who needs a special
assistant he has autism
he needs special assistance and special
school one day per week is not enough
for him
he is in a third grade he doesn't know
how to read write or spell
the economic fallout of the pandemic has
had far-reaching consequences
for children around the world as well as
losing out on their education
many are being forced prematurely into
work
in order to support families
every day when i come back home my hands
smell like gas
i take a shower have a meal sit with my
father and then go to sleep
i go to work from 9 am to 9 00 pm i work
for 12 hours
i do not want the corona pandemic to
affect my studies as i want to finish
them
to become a pilot and make my dream come
true
educational experts predict that 10
million of the world's most vulnerable
children
will fail to return to school and
they're urging the international
community to do all that is possible
to prevent more lives from being
disrupted and to get educators
vaccinated faster
so schools can open sooner rather than
later
the education community has understood
much more
the role that teachers play which is not
just the the role of instruction and
passing transmitting knowledge
it's their role as essentially leaders
in their communities and many
teachers around the world have really
done the most they could
to keep in touch with the students
especially the most disadvantaged and
that's something we should be really
cherishing
the pandemic may have exposed the
inequalities in education systems around
the world
but also the role that educators have in
students lives
which goes beyond just teaching sony
gallego
al jazeera